hi this is International Master David
Prowse for chess comm and today we are
going to learn how to use the Queen I
will not only be teaching you the rules
for how she moves that will take our
first 30 seconds or so but I will be
teaching you how to actually use her in
your games some basic strategy or you
know placement guidelines for how to use
the Queen effectively in chess so first
of all let's see how she moves she moves
in straight lines either sideways up and
down or on diagonals and as you can see
from the length of these arrows I'm
drawing she's allowed to move as far as
she likes along any one of these lines
as long as she does not bump into a pawn
or any other piece she cannot go past it
she could go there and capture it if
it's the opponent's piece or if it were
her own piece she can go up to the
square before her own piece so in this
position her movement possibilities
would now look like this clear so like
every piece other than the knight she
can't hop over pieces when she moves on
to the square another piece is on of the
opponent's she captures it and she can't
move on to squares occupied by her own
pieces she can move as you see like if
she's moving on this diagonal here she
can move to any of these four squares so
she can move 4 spaces or she can choose
to move only one space since she moves
both straight and diagonally
she's like a rook and a bishop right the
rook moves side to side up and down the
bishop moves along the diagonals so her
move is the combination of those two
pieces moves ok let us talk about what
the Queen's general strengths are one of
her abilities is speed she's one of the
fastest pieces on the board since she
can move as many squares as she wanted
to she moves as fast as the rook or the
bishop
because she can switch between moving
like a rook or a bishop it's harder for
her to get blocked rooks and bishops
will often get blocked like for example
here you see the white rook has kind of
blocked in on if the Queen chose to move
like a rook she would be blocked in um
but she could move like a bishop to get
out right and then she can start moving
like a rook if she wants to the Queen's
second advantage is double attacks she's
actually one of the best pieces no she
is the best piece for giving double
attacks or forks especially on open
boards where there are lots of open
lines for bishops or rooks right she
will be able to attack two things very
often for example here the best move for
white is actually to move the Queen
backwards showing the power she can have
from a distance she doesn't need to be
out in the thick of things like I'm one
of those squares in order to deliver
some serious threats he or she attacks
the rook she tacks the knight and white
actually picks up material in this
position just with that simple
retreating move with the Queen and
double attacks are a very common Forte
of the Queen's something to be looking
out for when you're playing with or
against her she is also very good at
checkmates because she covers a ton of
squares in a narrow area as well as
being able to move a long distance right
if you look how many spaces she covers
in a small space right she covers almost
enough squares to checkmate a king by
herself
in fact she only needs one helper to
cover one square and she's able to
deliver checkmate as in this position
here where she comes in and the pawn
defends the Queen but the Queen takes
away every single other possible square
and that's a checkmate so the Queen is
very good at giving checkmates and often
when you're attacking if you can get
your Queen into the vicinity of the
opponent's king that's going to be the
final moment in the attack and it's
going to lead to a checkmate now because
the Queen is really valuable you often
don't want to put her in front of your
other pieces because that is where
pieces get captured and trades are made
and the queen doesn't want to be traded
for any of the opponent's pieces
typically right so what kind of a
position do we normally put the Queen in
early in a game when we don't yet have
double attacks or things to attack or a
force around the opponent's king and you
want to swoop in and checkmate the
answer is the Queen usually takes a
position which is kind of like a
quarterback position what she likes to
be is somewhere in the middle of her own
sized position where she can swing to
one side or another to join whatever
attack or battle starts up she's the
fastest of getting from one area to the
next so she doesn't need to be really
close to participate in the battle and
you can bring her into what you want
very soon so this who are here for
example that she's on is already very
good square for her as we saw in the
first example where I was showing you a
double attack but here she blocks her
own rooks coordination
so what you'll most often see the Queen
on is one of these kind of squares here
she just lifts up onto the second-ranked
could be any of those three squares now
your rooks are free to move around your
queen can move on the second-ranked
she can also pretty quickly support
actions on various diagonals right and
which diagonal you think you're more
likely to use is how you choose whether
or not to back up this bishop or to you
know stay over here back up this bishop
and have this option etc but on these
kind of quarterback positions are
typically where you're placing your
queen early in the game so that as
things develop she can then swoop out
and join the attack in a decisive way
and now let me give you a note on where
to place your Queen in the endgame as
well Queen end games are extremely
complicated and difficult to play but
one single rule of thumb about them is
that your queen is best placed in a
certain area of the board do you think
it is the corner the side the center or
along the alleys
or is it near her own king or is it near
any past ponds is it far away from the
Kings the answer is generally speaking
the center the Queen will be best in the
center because she actually has more
moves in the center than on the side or
in the corners now as you may know rooks
always have 14 moves but bishops have
more moves if they're in the center on
longer diagonals and since the Queen is
partly a bishop like a bishop she has
slightly more moves here usually then
she had when she was over here okay
so typically you want to place her in
the center and the reason it's really
good for her to cover lots of squares is
that that's gonna help prevent your
opponent from giving perpetual check by
checking your King forever your queen is
going to cover a lot of squares and that
is going to help you to somehow get your
King out of check and hide him in the
middle of the board that's right so that
is how you want to place your Queen in
chess enjoy using the most powerful
piece on the board I hope you enjoyed
this video and I'll see you around on
chess calm